what a crazy experience this has been it
is the end of an era
you guys Adam Levine is leaving the
voice after 16 seasons that's right you
guys it's time to kiss goodbye to the
cute banter that we love so much between
Adam and his co-star Blake Shelton
because on Fridays Today Show Voice
hosts Carson Daly announced that the
maroon 5 frontman would be exiting the
singing competition show he'll always be
a cherished member of The Voice family
and of course we wish him nothing but
the best ah
so who will replace Adam get this I'm
happy to share this morning that Gwen
Stefani will be returning for season 17
when has sat in the chair before she met
her current boyfriend Blake Shelton
through the show and we're looking
forward to having when back okay so good
and bad news for Blake he gets to work
with his girl again but he loses his bro
the news apparently came as a shock to
the country star he tweeted that he was
still processing Adams exit having found
out about it less than a day before
Carson shared the news with the world
Adam won the first season of The Voice
in 2011 with Xavier Cologne really
amazing and that was really nervous
about being able to I wasn't sure what
my limitations are my capability would
be as a coach but I think I did a good
job then he wanted again in 2013 with
Tessanne chin
[Applause]
and again in 2015 with Jordan Smith it's
really quite beautiful because Jordan is
to win the voice and I get to tear Blake
apart for the next god
six months bragging about my win Gwen
was a coach on season 9 and season 12 of
the show but she hasn't won yet so it'll
be interesting to see how she does
this season news of Adam's exit comes
just days after the season 16 finale of
the boys Adam actually got kicked out
pretty early on in this season and John
Legend's contestant actually won when
you have Nathan on your team like she's
supposed to win the voice like her voice
is supposed to win the voice Blake and
Adam have always said that they'd only
do this show together so this really
does change things and in 2018 Adam told
ET that Hollywood's biggest bromance may
never have come about had it not been
for the voices executive producer
convincing him to join the show I
started a rumor Mark Burnett years ago
and Mike with my arms folded no way man
I'll never be on TV and he's like you
got to do he is so great at the time it
was a very risky decision so I felt like
it was scary and I wasn't so sure and to
be completely honest I wasn't sure what
was happening with the band and we were
kind of in this weird middle stage of
our career we weren't sure where I was
going but the voice became this very
unexpected a huge hit giant hit the
voice is such a great show or are you
gonna do it forever I mean forever is
all the forevers a long time but you
know as long as it it feels right you
know I think that it's it's you're right
you know it's one of those things that
just kind of never gets old because it's
a lot of fun doing your part to kind of
help these guys out on their own
personal quest and and it's fun it's
rewarding for us it's nice to be able to
give back the things that we've learned
they pay me really well
there really is just no downside they
shoot it in LA this is like come on the
best job and it makes the artist feel
good too I like making and making them
feel good and making them feel fortified
and better as they no matter how long
they stay on the show that's kind of our
job and I feel really good about how we
do it and he totally should feel good
it's going to be so sad to see him go
but don't worry guys we'll be here to
talk all things Adam Levine with you so
keep it locked on ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]